l'homme était fougue intel du gens
passionnés personne ne peut oublier son
départ fracassant de la vie politique
le chef du parti québécois avait obtenu
un vote de confiance de 76,2 pour 5
fâché et humilié bernard landry a claqué
la porte sur le coup j'ai démissionne
comme député de verchères et comme chef
de l'opposition
[Applaudissements]
il aurait fallu et le camp intransigeant
la scène le décrit à merveille
bernard landry est né à joliette en 1937
il étudie le droit à montréal et
l'économie à paris
jeune et brillant bernard landry a la
politique dans le sang
il a 27 ans quand rené lévesque alors
ministre des ressources naturelles du
gouvernement libéral de jean lesage le
recrutent au 500 cabines est il tentera
deux fois de se faire élire sans succès
et sera ministre d'état il réussira en
1976 dans fabre lorsque le parti
québécois prend le pouvoir il accède au
cabinet à titre de ministre d'état au
développement économique l'économie
devient sa marque de commerce
au tournant des années 80 l'ambitieux
ministre fait part de son intérêt pour
la direction du parti
mais la route sa route sera longue
en 85 et doit abandonner la course faute
d'appuis il cédera aussi sa place en 94
à jacques parizeau et ensuite à lucien
bouchard lucien bouchard fera toutefois
de lui un ministre ultra puissant il le
nomme vice premier ministre ministre des
finances du développement économique et
de l'industrie du commerce
c'est grâce à lui d'ailleurs que le
québec atteindra le déficit zéro avant
je voulais rentrer chez moi pour trouver
ma compagne en 1999 sa femme lorraine
laporte meurt d'un cancer à l'âge de 57
ans il est très bouleversée ils
redoublent d'ardeur au travail quand
lucien bouchard démissionne en 2001 le
grand jour est finalement venu pour
bernard landry il est couronné chef du
parti québécois et devient du coup
premier ministre du québec
le mot le plus caractéristique de notre
action dans les mois et les années qui
viennent
c'est le mot nous ensemble nous les
souverainistes
nous allons aller convaincre nos
compatriotes
il signera la paix des braves cette
importante entente avec l'écrit sur le
développement de la baie james
il fait aussi adopté une loi anti
pauvreté
mais bernard landry hérite d'un
gouvernement dont la cote de popularité
est à son plus bas
ils luttent contre le mécontentement sur
les fusions municipales forcé et sur les
compressions dans le secteur de la santé
quelques scandales éclaboussent souci
son gouvernement
il déclenche des élections générales en
2003 quand on a un bon gouvernement
on le garde malgré une campagne
vigoureuse
il perd les libéraux de jean charest
prenne le pouvoir
il n'aura donc jamais été premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mais malgré la défaite il veut faire sa
marque et parce qu'il ne veut pas
laisser de partie aux mains de pauline
marois ou françois legault il décide de
rester le poste de président de parti
québécois n'est donc pas vacant il
engage son parti dans une profonde
remise en question la saison des idées
entre temps la diffusion d'un
documentaire tourné durant la campagne
électorale lui attire plus de
sympathiques
[Musique]
le documentaire le rend plus humain et
le public découvre celle qui deviendra
sa deuxième femme chantal renou elle
accompagne partout lorsque québec sera
considéré pour ce qu'il est une nation
mais son leadership et menaces y
françois legault et pauline marois se
livrent à des manigances qui divise le
parti
jusqu'à ce que pauline marois réclame
ouvertement une course à la direction
un changement quinta la conviction que
j'ai maintenant acquise que ça devait
passer par là pour la suite des choses
un défi qui passera par un vote de
confiance qu'il estimera avoir perdu oui
à 76,2 pour ça et qui pave la voie à la
fin de sa carrière politique
bernard landry retourne enseigner à
l'uqam
mais sa passion pour la politique est
toujours présente et commentera
régulièrement dans les médias
les décisions de ses successeurs c'est
ont dit on va pratiquer la gouvernement
source
ça veut dire se comporter comme se tait
souverain sans l'aide alors ça donne
qu'elle ne sache à la population si on
peut gouverner ce run et s'enlève
pourquoi travailler pour la souveraineté
bernard landry est resté jusqu'à la fin
un fervent militant souverainiste ici
martin biron radio canada québec